[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert König
mit hochkarätigem Sport absolut
historisches Finale in Paris guten Abend
schauen wir auf die Nachrichten Themen
dieses Sonntags
Partner für neue Asylpolitik gesucht die
EU stellt Tunesien Finanzhilfen in
Aussicht im Gegenzug soll das Land die
illegale Migration begrenzen
was braucht die Wirtschaft im Osten in
Brandenburg geht es beim
Wirtschaftsforum auch um
Fachkräftemangel und
Zukunftstechnologien
und die neuen Könige von Europa
Manchester City feiert den ersten
Champions League Titel der
Vereinsgeschichte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn die EU Tunesien langfristig mit 900
Millionen Euro winkt wie heute in Tunis
dann geht es nicht nur um Hilfe für das
wirtschaftlich angeschlagene Land es
geht auch darum dass Tunesien seine
Grenzen für Flüchtlinge besser überwacht
und damit der EU hilft denn die Mehrheit
der Menschen die übers Mittelmeer den
Weg nach Italien wagt kommt über
Tunesien das sagt das
UN-Flüchtlingskommissariat seit
Jahresbeginn erreichten insgesamt mehr
als
53.800 Migranten die italienischen Küste
im Jahr davor waren es zur gleichen Zeit
etwa 21.700
die küstenstadts Fax in Tunesien nur
knapp 200 km entfernt von der
italienischen Insel Lampedusa gerade
Flüchtlinge aus Westafrika machen sich
von hier auf den Weg nach Europa viele
trinken Mittelmeer aber die Hoffnung auf
ein besseres Leben wird sie nicht
stoppen und wenn sie mich tausendmal zur
Umkehr zwingen ich versuche es wieder
Tunesien erlebt eine schwere
Wirtschaftskrise für Präsident seit
belasten die Flüchtlinge sein Land die
EU will aber nicht mehr so viele
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen bietet deshalb
Tunesien Finanzhilfen an
Tunesien soll in diesem Jahr hundert
Millionen Euro von der EU bekommen um
allein seine Grenzen besser zu schützen
mit dem Geld wollen wir auch
Rettungsaktionen finanzieren und das
Geschäft der Schlepper bekämpfen
die Lebensumstände vieler Flüchtlinge in
Tunesien sind hart viele sprechen von
zunehmenden Anfeindungen die EU weiß und
das umstrittene Verhalten der
tunesischen Regierung deshalb stellt sie
heute noch einmal klar
alle Kontrollen dürfen natürlich nicht
die Menschenrechte der Flüchtlinge
verletzen
Europa sucht Lösungen für sein
Flüchtlingsproblem eine mehr Geld für
Länder wie Tunesien die bereit sind die
Flüchtlinge auf dem Weg nach Europa zu
stoppen
in die Ukraine wo so viel ist inzwischen
klar Angriffe auf russische Einheiten in
den besetzten Gebieten laufen wie die
Situation sich dort entwickelt lässt
sich derzeit nicht sagen sowohl Kiew als
auch Moskau reklamieren Erfolge für sich
christophell
russlandsverteidigungsminister verleiht
Orden an Teilnehmer der sogenannten
militärischen spezialoperation er lobt
ihren Mut und sagt dann
ich bin sicher dass Sie unserem
Vaterland auch weiterhin treu dienen
werden
gleichzeitig lässt der Kreml klar wie
selten wissen derzeit gäbe es nicht
einmal eine hauchdünne Grundlage für
Friedensverhandlungen heißt für die
Soldaten auch mit Orden wohl zurück ins
Kriegsgebiet besonders umkämpft die
Region sapodicia dort versucht die
ukrainische Armee offenbar Richtung
Süden vorzustoßen um das russisch
besetzte Gebiet zu spalten nördlich der
Front liegt Uli Griff seit Monaten
beschießen sich in der Gegend beide
Seiten Moskau veröffentlicht Bilder
angeblich von erfolgreichen
Drohnenangriffen und von zerstörten
Panzern die Ukraine will mindestens
einen Ort im besetzten Gebiet befreit
haben was solche Meldung bedeuten im
Moment völlig unklar
nah dran er macht talerie Feuer in oder
Schiff leben Menschen in Trümmern auf
den ukrainischen Vorstoß setzen sie ihre
Hoffnungen und fürchten ihn gleichzeitig
wie gesagt das Gefühl dass der große sie
kommt aber in der Stadt ist es viel
unsicherer geworden
erst gestern wurde dieses Haus getroffen
ein Ehepaar 52 und 53 Jahre alt kam ums
Leben viele werden wohl noch sterben bei
den Kämpfen im Süden von denen
Beobachter sagen wahrscheinlich
entscheidet sich hier ob die Ukraine die
Besatzer zurückschlagen können wann auch
das völlig unklar
nach Deutschland die Führung der Linken
bekommt bei ihrem Umgang mit Sahra
Wagenknecht Gegenwind aus der eigenen
Partei der frühere Vorsitzende ernst und
der frühere parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der Fraktion Ulrich
forderten den Vorstand zum Rücktritt auf
dessen Beschluss des Sahra Wagenknecht
ihr Bundestagsmandat zurückgeben solle
spaltet die Partei hintergrund des
Streits ist das Wagenknecht die Gründung
einer eigenen Partei erweckt
jedes Jahr im Juni wird Bad Saarow in
Brandenburg zur großen polit- und
wirtschaftsbühne dort startete heute das
ostdeutsche Wirtschaftsforum mit viel
Zuversicht beim Bundeskanzler er sagt
Ostdeutschland könne zum Wachstumsmotor
werden allerdings bremst auch hier der
Fachkräftemangel Nikola Albrecht nicht
nur die Temperaturen lassen Politik und
ostdeutsche Wirtschaft Elite am
idyllischen Scharmützelsee schwitzen es
geht um die aktuellen Herausforderungen
in einer neuen Zeit so das Motto des
Forums das Kanzler Olaf Scholz eröffnet
wenn die Zukunft gehört den erneuerbaren
Energien sie sind schon heute die
preiswerteste Art Energie zu produzieren
auf erneuerbare Energien setzen auch Sie
wollen den Traum vom umweltfreundlichen
fliegen war werden lassen und zwar in
den nächsten zehn Jahren mit Hilfe von
grünem Wasserstoff der Standort
Brandenburg sei dafür optimal so
Geschäftsführer Philipp Scheffel
wir haben viele Windräder viele
Solaranlagen das heißt
Energiequellen um grünen Wasserstoff zu
erzeugen und deswegen ist Brandenburg in
guter Ausgangspunkt um emissionsfreie
Technologien zu entwickeln was sind
brems sind die mangelnden Fachkräfte für
die Unternehmer im Osten laut einer
aktuellen Umfrage die größte
Herausforderung das Lohnniveau ist hier
nach wie vor niedriger und die aktuelle
Stärke der AFD in den Umfragen Strecke
viele vom Umzug in den Osten ab auch
darüber wird hier diskutiert
es ist in manchen Regionen signifikanter
ja ich setze letztendlich auf die zu den
Zusammenhalt und auch den Verstand der
Menschen dass sie
dass sie das selbst auch mit in die Hand
nehmen die Verantwortung auch übernehmen
und für die Regierung gilt klug zu
handeln geschlossen zu handeln drei Tage
debattieren sie hier am Scharmützelsee
morgen dann mit Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck
die Stimmung war gelöst die Herzen offen
der Verstand klar so die Bilanz der
Veranstalter nach fünf Tagen
evangelischer Kirchentag in Nürnberg zum
Abschluss am Vormittag kamen rund 25.000
Menschen zu zwei Gottesdiensten im
Mittelpunkt stand dabei der Aufruf zum
Handeln angesichts der Krisen unserer
Zeit es war ein hochpolitischer
Kirchentag mit Debatten etwa über die
Klimakrise oder den Krieg in der Ukraine
und jetzt noch ein Literaturpreis für
den Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
hat in Frankfurt den mit 20.000 Euro
dotierten Ludwig Börne Preis bekommen
habe überzeuge als Publizist und Redner
mit Klarheit und Einfühlsamkeit hieß es
bei der Preisverleihung in der
Paulskirche außerdem wieder setze er
sich der Verwilderung der politischen
Kommunikation
und auch Inter Mailand hat sich lang
widersetzt Norbert gestern Abend im
Champions League Finale ja und sie
hatten ihre Chancen aber am Ende jubelt
wie erwartet der englische Meister
Manchester City nicht geglänzt beim 1:0
Istanbul aber den königsklassentitel
gewonnen zum ersten Mal in der
Vereinsgeschichte
für pep Guardiola ist es der dritte
Champions League Titel als Trainer für
fast alle seine Spieler dagegen das
erste Mal wenn man das dritte Finale
spielt und die zweite vor verloren hat
das erste vor zehn Jahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch mental auch 67 Minuten lang
verteidigt Inter intelligent und mutig
doch einmal kommt Manchester City durch
rothri mit der Entscheidung wir haben
mindestens mal auf Augenhöhe gespielt
hatten vielleicht sogar auf die 90
Minuten gesehen die besseren Torchancen
aber ja so ist leider das Game Inter
Mailand dreht nach Manchester noch mal
auf die Marco an die Latte und auf
Kopfballvorlage von großens Lukaku dich
dran am Ausgleich es bleibt beim eins zu
0 Gündogan und großen treffen sich
Mittwoch wieder bei der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft
und am Montag gegen die Ukraine fehlt
neben Gündogan und großen ist auch der
angeschlagene Timo Werner das 1.000ste
dfb-länderspiel morgen ab 17:35 Uhr bei
uns im ZDF
Tennisprofi Nowak jokovic hat den Rekord
sein dritter triumphos ist
gleichbedeutend mit dem 23 Grand Slam
Titel desserben einen weniger hat der
derzeit verletzte Rafael Nadal mit 36
Jahren ist Djokovic nach seinem
letztlich klaren aber umkämpften
Dreisatz Erfolg gegen Kasper ruht
außerdem der älteste Turniersieger der
French open-geschichte der 12 Jahre
jüngere Norweger musste sich nach drei
ein Viertelstunden mit sechs zu sieben
drei zwei sechs fünf sieben
und auch der THW Kiel freut sich über
seine 23 die 23 deutsche
handballmeisterschaft der Männer das
letzte Saisonspiel in Göppingen war nur
noch Formsache dass 34 zu 27 war
gleichzeitig die Abschiedsvorstellung
von Torhüter Niklas Landin und Torjäger
Sander sargosen der Norweger nochmals
erfolgreichster Wörter mit sieben
Treffern Kiel und die um zwei Punkte
schlechteren Titelverteidiger aus
Magdeburg sind qualifiziert für die
Champions League
und damit durch durch den Sport viele
strahlende Sieger waren das am Wetter
ändert sich wenig die Woche beginnt
meist sonnig dabei weht ein schwacher
bismäßiger Ostwind die Höchsttemperatur
liegt zwischen 23 Grad auf Rügen und am
Alpenrand und 32 Grad am Niederrhein
9:45 Uhr begrüßt Sie Marietta Slomka im
heute-journal hier übernimmt morgen Jana
pareises wir sagen danke und tschüss